what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about plate tectonics plate
tectonics and you've probably heard the
word before and are probably or you
might be somewhat somewhat familiar with
what it what it discusses and it's
really just the idea that the surface
that the surface of the earth is made up
of a bunch of these rigid plates so it's
broken up into a bunch of rigid plates
and these rigid plates move relative to
each other they move relative to each
other and take everything that's on them
for ride and the things that are on them
include the continents so the literally
is talking about the movement of these
plates and over here I have a picture I
got off of Wikipedia of the actual
plates and over here you have the
Pacific plate let me do that in a darker
color you have a Pacific plate you have
a Nazca plate you have a South American
plate I could keep going on you have an
Antarctic plate it's actually obviously
whenever you do a projection onto two
dimensions of a surface of a sphere the
stuff at the bottom and the top look
much bigger than they actually are
Antarctica isn't this big relative to
say North America or South America it's
just that we've had to stretch it out to
fill up with the rectangle but that's
the Antarctic plate North American plate
and you can see that they're actually
moving relative to each other and that's
what these arrows that's what these
arrows are depicting you see right over
here the Nazca plate and the Pacific
plate are moving away from each other
new land is forming here we'll talk more
about that in other videos you see right
over here in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean the African plate and the South
American plate meet each other and
they're moving away from each other
which means that new land more plate
material I guess you could say is being
is somehow being created right here
we'll talk about that in future videos
and pushing and pushing these two plates
apart now before we go into the evidence
for plate tonics or even some of the
more details about how plates are
created and and some theories as to why
the plates might move what I want to do
is get a little bit of the terminology
of plate tectonics out of the way
because sometimes people call them
crustal plates and that's not exactly
right and to show you the difference
what I want to do is show you two
different ways of classifying the
different layers of the earth and then
think about how they
might relate to each other so what you
traditionally see and actually I've made
a video that goes into a lot more detail
of this is a chemical is the breakdown
of the chemical layers of the earth when
I talk about chemical layers I'm talking
about what are the dip what are the
constituents of the different layers so
when you talk of it in this term the
topmost layer which is the thinnest
layer is the crust is the crust then
below that is the mantle below that is
the mantle actually let me do it let me
show you the whole earth although I'm
not going to draw it to scale so if I
were to draw the crust the crust is the
outer the thinnest outer layer of the
earth you can imagine the blue line
itself is the crust then below that you
have the mantle so everything between
the blue and the orange line is this
over here is the mantle mantle let me
label the crust the crust you can
literally view as the actual blue pixels
over here and then inside of the mantle
you have the core and when you do this
very high-level division we talk these
are chemical divisions this is saying
that the crust is made up of different
types of elements its makeup is
different than the stuff that's in then
the stuff that's in the mantle which is
made up of different things then it
what's inside of the core it's not
describing the mechanical properties of
it and when I talk about mechanical
properties I'm talking about whether
something is so mechanical properties
mechanical properties are whether
something is a solid solid and rigid or
maybe it's kind of a it's so hot and
melted it's kind of a magma or a kind of
a plastic solid so then you know this
would be the the the the most brittle
stuff if it gets warmed up if rock
starts to melt a little bit then you
have something like a magma or you can
view it as like a deformable or a
plastic solid and we talk about plastic
I'm not talking about you know the stuff
that you're the case of your cell phone
is made up I'm talking about its
deformable this rock is deformable
because it's so hot and it's somewhat
melted it has somewhat it kind of
behaves like a fluid it actually
behave like a fluid but it's much more
viscous it's much thicker and slower
moving than what we would normally
associate with the fluid like water so
this is this is viscous this is a
viscous fluid and then the most fluid
would of course be the liquid state
would be the liquid state this is what
we mean when we talk about the
mechanical properties and when you look
at these when you look at this division
over here the crust is solid the crust
is solid the mantle actually has some
parts of it that are solid so the
uppermost part of the mantle is solid
then below that it has a kind of the
rest of the mantle is kind of in this
magma this deformable somewhat fluid
state and depending on what depth you go
into the mantle there they're kind of
different levels of fluidity and then
the core the outer level layer of the
core the outer core is liquid because
the temperature so high the inner core
is made up with the same things and the
temperature is even higher
but since the pressure so high it's
actually solid so that's why the mantle
crust and core differentiations don't
tell you about mechanical salt whether
it's whether it's solid whether it's
magma or whether it's really a liquid it
just really tells you what the makeup is
now to think about the makeup and this
is important for plate tectonics so when
we talk about these plates we're not
talking about just the crust we're
talking about the outer rigid layer and
we talked about that let me just zoom in
a little bit let me just zoom it listen
let's say we zoomed in right over there
so now we have the crust zoomed in this
right here is the crust and then
everything below here we're actually
talking about the upper mantle so we're
talking about
we haven't gotten too deep in the mantle
right here so that's why we call it the
upper mantle upper up or the upper
mantle no right below the crust the
mantle is cool enough that it is also in
in real solid form so this right here
this right here is solid solid mantle
and when we talk about the plates we're
actually talking about the outer solid
layer so that includes
that includes both the crust and the
solid part of the mantle
and we call that the lithosphere the
lithosphere that when we when people
talk about plate tectonics they
shouldn't say crustal plates they should
call these lithospheric plates litho
lithospheric and then below the
lithosphere you have you have the least
viscous part of the mantle because the
temperature is high enough the
temperature is high enough for the rock
to melt but the pressure isn't so big
that it's the the the pressure isn't so
large as what will happen when you go
into the lower part of the mantle that
the fluid can actually kind of move past
each other although still pretty viscous
it's still a magma so we can this is
still kind of in its magma State and
this this fluid part of the mantle we
can't quite call it a liquid yet but it
over large periods of time it does have
fluid properties this that essentially
the lithosphere is kind of riding on top
of we call this the asthenosphere as
then no sphere so when we talk about the
lithosphere and asthenosphere we're
really talking about mechanical layers
the outer layer the solid layers the
lithosphere the more fluid layer right
below that's the asthenosphere when we
talk about the crust mantle and core we
are talking about chemical properties
what are the things actually made up of